hey it's me I thought we're gonna talk
about a video I made a year ago it was
about happiness it was about forced
positivity remember that video I don't
think being happy all the time is
something desirable at all now if you
watch my older videos I might seem a lot
happier I might see a lot cheaper a lot
more positive and that's because I faked
it basically I talked about how a lot of
youtubers had to keep up this sort of
facade of happiness and oh look how
great everything is to sort of draw
people in and be entertained by you
because no one likes to hear I mostly
asked people people are generally drawn
to happiness and I got really fed up and
really tired of keeping this facade that
yeah I'm really enjoying this game I'm
really having a great time playing this
game oh wow I sure love playing
Minecraft every single day for years the
video prompted a lot of responses and a
lot of discussion and I thought it was
really interesting and healthy and great
thing in general that we brought it up I
remember really just playing games and
in the back of my head I was like I'm
really hating this game I'm really not
entertained by this but I sort of had
this idea in my head that well it's my
job and people want me to play it so I
should just do it and you know but it
wasn't fulfilling for me and it wasn't
making me happy and I noticed recently a
lot of streamers and youtubers talking
about this sort of saying that they
don't feel very happy or as happy as
they used to be they they don't feel
fulfilled it's a damn shame
and I see a lot of people in the
comments sort of being like well it's
your job you should just suck it up it's
not that hard
YouTube it's not a job which is true by
the way it's not a job but I always feel
bad when I see this because I can relate
to the the entertainer I can
can understand their perspective and so
I thought I would make a video just sort
of explaining that perspective is I
think I think it's important for for
everyone the the problem with being a
youtuber on an online entertainer is
that you constantly have to outdo
yourself to keep people interested in
what you are doing you have to
constantly keep pushing boundaries and
you are essentially competing more or
less with other entertainers and other
youtubers for for the audience to give
you the time that you want this is not
just to keep up your YouTube channel or
whatever is also to keep up your
livelihood imagine your job or whatever
you do being a competition it's it's not
a healthy thing and I think a lot of
people get swept up in that but they
have to keep pushing himself and I think
it's it's a good reflection of what
happened with Logan Paul I know I keep
bringing it up and that's not my point
here I don't think Logan necessarily is
a bad person I just think he really got
caught up in that idea that he has to
keep pushing himself to get those
numbers if you make videos every single
day it's really tough to keep make
people keep being interested and keep
coming back so I can sort of understand
it and I can sort of relate to it in a
way for me personally I was really
miserable before YouTube YouTube is only
really just done so many amazing thing
to me and I I don't want to seem like
I'm complaining I'm I couldn't be
happier but I think I still even though
I talked about this a lot I think a lot
of people have this illusion in their
head that money and fame is gonna bring
them some sort of happiness and I think
a lot of youtubers and a lot of
entertainers when they get this get to
the point where actually I have
everything I want or thought I wanted
but I don't feel happy and I don't feel
fulfilled and that just makes them even
more unhappy and less fulfilled and
it's a very it can be a very negative
thing even though it's maybe might be
hard to understand as an audience as a
silent viewer or whatever a few years
ago all I used to do was YouTube it was
seven days a week now I do six days a
week I would make videos i'ma go wake up
go to my room make videos and that was
it I didn't have any hobbies I didn't
have any other interests I wouldn't hang
out with friends and looking back that
was an extremely unhealthy thing to do
and I would do whatever videos my fans
wanted me to do the fans that I have
gotten because I had this very serious
approach to YouTube you know it's my job
I have to keep doing this I am so lucky
to be in this position I have to respect
it my personal well-being or health
that's number two but it got to a point
for me where I just felt like enough
this is not making me happy I don't want
to keep doing this am either gonna quit
it or I'm just gonna say all right well
I'm gonna do it my way and if I lose a
couple friends in the process then I can
afford that I'm in a position where I
can afford doing that and I was really
ready for my channel to just come down
crashing and that would be it but at
least then I would be fulfilled at least
I would be happier I was met with a lot
of criticism a lot of a lot of angry
fans that said oh you were not playing
amnesia you've really changed or you're
not playing this game anymore you really
changed but eventually it took some time
but eventually he broke through and all
the sudden I had people loving what I
was doing because there was actual
passion behind it there was actual
things that I enjoyed that I could share
I got hobbies that I really enjoyed and
I could share those as well like I wish
skied videos something I enjoy and I
started exercising meeting friends and
all these things that I used to do and
it just it made such a huge difference
for me and it might just seem obvious
but when you're so swept up into you to
me it really isn't and it also had the
opposite effect that I thought my
channel will go down but it it did
really well either either way my advice
to a lot of youtubers and entertain
do what makes you happy if you lose some
fans in the process I think in the in
the end it will be worth it and I think
a lot of us need to stop taking their
own personal health after whatever it is
they're doing I am really in the the
best place I ever been and I'm just
having a blast with YouTube and
everything I'm doing right now and I'm
so happy I made that choice and that's
sort of why I wanted to share this and I
also wanted to give some insight for you
guys to understand yes YouTube isn't
really a job but it's also if it can
also be extremely tough and it extremely
weighing you down it's the easiest and
the toughest job I ever done it's not
like I don't want people to pat me on
the back being like yeah it is a really
tough you're doing a great job that's
not it at all
but I you don't deserve to be slapped in
the face for it either be happy be nice
to each other and have a good smile
everybody for every once in a while make
sure to smile and also make sure to
leave a like on this video if you found
it helpful at all clap it up everybody I
need an outro if anyone can help me with
that a brofist ah there you go did it I
did the I did the pandering